he is the man over at roto World fantasy
football obviously Evan optimism is high
for everybody listening in their fantasy
football leagues let's start with the
Patriots and what we need to know in
your mind in terms of who are the right
guys to play and not to play tonight and
moving forward now that join Edelman's
out for the year yeah in that slot role
in New England has been extremely
productive historically you can think
back to Wes Welker and then Julian
Edelman so it spans longer than a decade
the position has just been extremely
fruitful and not with guys who were
necessarily highly thought of at any
other point in their careers really Wes
Welker was an undrafted guy who didn't
have great measurables the Patriots
stole him away from the Dolphins as a
restricted free agent and even Julian
Edelman he was a converted quarterback
seventh round pick out of Kent State who
actually hit the free agent market
previously and didn't even generate much
interest from other NFL teams but what
those guys didn't have they made up for
with just trust from Tom Brady on your
timing routes and option routes and I
think that in his second year with the
Patriots we're gonna see that Chris
Hogan has that chemistry with Tom Brady
and we saw flashes of it in the third
preseason game which teams treat like a
regular season dress-rehearsal
the big flashy offseason acquisition
Brandon cooks was quiet in that game but
Brady and Chris Hogan were on the same
page in lockstep Brady targeted Hogan
four times in that game Hogan caught all
four for 70 yards and two touchdowns I
think we see Chris Hogan get off to a
really hot start tonight against the
Chiefs who just lost their starting slot
Corner Steven Nelson two injured reserve
and their backup slot Corner Phillip
Gaines allowed an almost perfect 140 3.8
passer rating on throws into his
coverage in the slot last year so I
think that Chris Hogan is going to eat
up Philly gains inside so I know that
most people's drafts are over at this
point obviously but I still want to know
whether it's for Daly or for who to sit
or or play who's the right guy to own in
the Patriots backfield is it James White
is it Burke head is it Gillis Lee who's
the guy everyone assumed that my deal is
Lee would be the Patriots one for one
replacement for LeGarrette Blount when
the Patriots signed him away from the
bills but my girls Lee wound up barely
practicing in the spring due to a
hamstring strain and then he really
didn't get healthy until the end of
training camp and there have been some
whispers that the Patriots are down on
Gillis Lee and I'll be interested to see
the Patriots inactive list tonight when
it comes out about an hour and a half
before the game I think there's a chance
that Gillis Lee is gonna actually be
inactive for this game I'm not saying
that that's likely but I think that
there's a chance especially after the
Patriots just resend Brandon Bolden
because now look at the Patriots 53 they
have five backs on there 53 they have
Mike Gillis Lee Brandon Bolden Dion
Lewis James white and Rex Burkett and
because Bolden is so valued on special
teams I think he's going to dress and
play and so someone here is probably not
gonna address and I wonder if it might
be Gillis Lee I think that Rex Burkhead
might have a breakout game on Thursday
night the Chiefs were not good against
the run last year and I don't think
they're going to be very good against
the run this year and we've seen the
Patriots attack inside linebackers who
they deem pass coverage liabilities
before whether it was Bernard Rick
McKinney on wheel routes with their
running backs in the playoffs and when
they would play the Steelers they just
run Julian Edelman relentlessly at
Lawrence Timmons and Edelman would rack
up catches and I think Rex Burkhead and
James white can both be used in those
capacities so I think that James White
or Rex Burkhead both have a pretty good
shot at having big games tonight talking
with my buddy Evan Silva from rota world
you can check him out every week on the
fantasy feast podcast as well speaking
of that Evan we had our draft last night
and I took Kareem Hunt who looks to be
the running back I guess with the Chiefs
pretty much full time and also Tyree
kill I wanted to get your thoughts on
those two guys the rookie running back
hunt as well as Tyree kill and what kind
of points you think he'll be able to put
up yeah Kareem hunt should be
lead back tonight I think we'll see star
Kendrick wet west mix in a little bit on
passing downs as a pass blocker he's
just gonna be a guy that the Chiefs have
a lot of trust in Kareem hunt missed his
first NFL game with Tyree killed you
know he was obviously a super explosive
player as a rookie I mean he was a
highlight reel machine he had only 85
offensive touches all year where he
scored 12 touchdowns and now the Chiefs
are trying to shoehorn Tyreke Hill into
their lead receiver role because they
had to cut Jeremy Maclin
because of their bad salary cap
situation and then we saw them fire
their GM John Dorsey which may have been
a fallout from that either way now they
are relying on Tyreke Hill to be less of
a manufactured touch gadget guy and more
of a true white out but if you go back
and look at Tyreke Hills college resume
he never had a season where he called
600 rooms so his resume historically
just does not really suggest that he is
a true wide receiver so I'm interested
to see how he fares in this new role he
gets a he starts off with a tough
matchup right off the bat against
Stephon Gilmore and Malcom Butler I
think we'll mainly see Malcolm Butler
matchup with Tyreke and Stephon Gilmore
Stephon Gilmore mostly matchup with
Chris Conley because Gilmour is a bigger
a longer arm guy and Conley is bigger
and I think the Patriots will want to
get physical with Tyreke he'll and
Malcolm Butler is small but he's really
physical and the paint the patch has
hate to give up big plays so I would not
be surprised if they actually devote
more resources to dealing with Tyreke
kill than they do with Travis Kelce in
this particular game okay so let's move
on from tonight's game let's get to the
weekend who are the best plays and the
worst plays this weekend whether it's to
put in your season-long lineup or daily
fantasy or whatever who have the best
and worst matchups I really like Larry
Fitzgerald against the Lions I think he
can have a big day against quandary
Diggs or DJ Haden or whoever the Lions
run out there at slot Corner the Lions
top corner Darius slay never moves
inside and Fitzgerald runs 60 to 70
percent of his routes inside and that
old Hines Ward Reggie Wayne roll
Larry Fitz also has a history of
starting seasons really
I like Zach Ertz a lot against the
Redskins the Eagles traded jordan
matthews their slot receiver who played
in the same sections of the field that
Earths does and in two games jordan
matthews missed last year due to
injuries Zach Ertz was huge he had 15
targets in a game against the Bengals
caught nine balls for 79 yards touchdown
and then the other one Earths had 16
targets and caught 13 balls for 130 9s
and for 139 yards and two touchdowns
against Dallas and with sOooo Cravens
the Redskins
projected starting strong safety no
longer with the team I think that Zach
Ertz get gets a matchup boost a couple
of guys who I think have concerning week
one matchups are Michael Thomas on
Monday night against Xavier Rhodes which
I think could translate to a sneaky big
game for Ted Ginn especially with Willie
Snead on suspension Dez Bryant got shut
down twice by John Orr's Jenkins last
season so from that standpoint Dez has a
fairly concerning matchup on Sunday
Night Football
the Broncos historically have really had
so look rivers number so I would be
concerned about rivers playing in Denver
in the second game of that Monday night
doubleheader Evan really appreciate the
time thank you so much for coming on the
show thank you the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience